that's here we are here it is is the
last Harry Potter movie I have to review
before these reviews catch up to the
reviews I already did before ultimately
were trans days after this one I will
have reviewed all the Harry Potter films
I have captain life it's all downhill
from here
bring on death
[Music]
Harry Potter and the half-blood Prince
so Harry Potter and the half-blood
Prince ultimately should be Harry Potter
second to last year at Hogwarts but it
ends up being his last year at Hogwarts
so is the second to the last story and
as always there will be spoilers in this
review so if you haven't seen Harry
Potter and the half-blood Prince crazy
but not even more so ultimately the
premise of this story is Dumbledore
brings a new teacher to Hogwarts
Slughorn and you find out Slughorn has a
secret he has a memory that he has
altered so Dumbledore can't actually see
the real memory but something this guy
told Tom Riddle aka Voldemort years ago
is key in defeating him so they need to
get it out of them do we have things
like Draco Malfoy being a creep he's up
to something what's he up to
Harry gets a new potions book formerly
owned by the half-blood Prince and
they're all getting girlfriends and
stuff and once again what I liked about
this story is the mystery of it every
Potter is good at that in the end at the
core of all of these there's a mystery
there's something to solve now this
story is funny to me Harry Potter and
the half-blood Prince is my favorite
Harry Potter book not my favorite Harry
Potter movie just for warning you I'm
going to be that annoying person for a
second and by a second I mean for a few
minutes in this video where I compare
the movie to the book and I'm going to
be that guy who's like this disease
better they should have kept visiting
the book apologies in advance man I know
but this one really hits me in that
direction so I got to speak on it that
to say I don't like it this movie has a
lot to enjoy in a world where tensions
are up you're really intrigued as to
what does this guy know actually like
Horace Slughorn although he's kind of
creepy with his weird little dinners he
has a student yeah that's that's a news
story waiting to happen
that's a pretty intense scene by the end
the big thing goes down on this one but
in terms of the book-to-movie
translation this movie cut a lot of book
lore out I'm talking really important
things about Voldemort's past about Tom
Riddle the bummer is these things are
what made the half-blood Prince my
favorite book and that I'm not mad at
the movie I'm just disappointed it's the
back story - the villain never we guys
have a few moments of the field I really
love where the movie takes you with
Malfoy not like it goes full deep into
Draco Malfoy's mindset or anything like
that but there are a couple moments in
this movie where you really get the
feeling you're like okay it's been so
easy to hate this kid all this year oh
really he is a victim of his own
circumstance he's a victim of his life
it's never he's kind of crying at this
sink and the big tragedy is he and Harry
get into a fight because Harry confronts
him I feel like if Harry had approached
him in a more understanding manner it
could have been an olive branch Thurman
Pepa says it's easy for us to hate
Malfoy all these years and it's been
easy for Harry do also over the first
time ever I really did feel bad for
Malfoy
although for the entirety of the Harry
Potter story that you've seen thus far
he does the worst things he's ever done
in this chapter hello I felt bad for the
kid we see Dumbledore and Harry go out
on an adventure together and it's
actually a pretty intense scene I really
like the scene in the movie I really
like Jim Broadbent in this movie it's
one to play Slughorn he's one of the
cases when I was reading the half-blood
Prince book I was like this dude reminds
me of Jim Broadbent
and they got him for the movie just
really makes me think JK Rowling write
these roles with actors in mind in which
case Marvel Oh got from the book that
Daniel day-lewis totally would have been
Daniel day-lewis if he were in the movie
at all I'm just saying of all the stuff
you could have cut out of the story to
save time to put it on the screen like
cut out the Voldemort stuff when you
could have cut out the romance I said
the romance in this story really does
nothin for me it makes it whimsical and
fun remind you they are still in school
oh really I find it absurd that any of
these people ended up together in the
end did Harry have to wind up with wrong
sister did Hermione have to wind up with
Ron odds are these people would grow up
find other romances all have pot Luck's
together but marrying different people
less that makes them high school
romances how often those work out now
you don't want to go down that road
that's what's missing from this movie
half-blood Prince we are on the eve of
it man The Wizarding World of d-day is
right around the corner and we don't
really get Voldemort there's nothing
he's not in here that could have gone
for a little more of at least his past
one of my favorite moments in the entire
Harry Potter saga of everything is
actually in the book for half-blood
Prince it's this moment where Dumbledore
and Voldemort sit down across the desk
and they talk but it was a really cool
moment got a gun for a moment like that
in here and this is the big spoiler here
okay so in the book I stop I'm that guy
in the book when Dumbledore dies it is
set up differently and I do think the
direction they went in the movie
actually does some characters a
disservice in the book when Dumbledore
dies when Malfoy confronts Dumbledore
then all the other Death Eaters come in
and they're there to hurry is under his
invisibility cloak and Dumbledore has
him frozen with a spell that's why Harry
can't move he can't do anything he
wouldn't be good began then snake comes
in he's still cloaked he's still frozen
Snape kills Dumbledore and you're left
with that oh my gosh he's so the bad guy
Harry had to watch it happen he couldn't
do anything this as that however in the
movie Harry is look under the
floorboards is on the second level I
guess it would be the
before it anyhow he's in the floor under
them but he can still see what's
happening he could do something about it
but he doesn't I know Dumbledore told
him not to but still I feel like that's
not enough now when you see your mentor
is in peril dangers around snakes right
there and snake goes has his wand to him
and he walks past him he goes up there
and then you know I was always left with
that feeling of like you could have
killed Harry you could have brought him
up like hey we have another one here
let's kill them both if he was actually
bad we didn't do that so you walk away
from the movie like I'm not convinced
Snape as a bad guy where is in the book
you put it down you close it like [ __ ]
yeah maybe people felt that in this
movie I just didn't get that opportunity
guys in the end I know it feels like I
really went in on this movie hard but
this movie does have frustrations for me
it's still completely enjoyable it has
what you come to expect the intrigue
with the intensity and the execution of
the plans that are going down in here
and good guys are not really winning by
the end I like it all I just would have
loved for them to cut out some other
things and make room for the Voldemort
backstory that I feel is important to
his character
maybe it's unfair to judge it by the
book I know I have felt that way when I
have seen people do that in review I
just I can't deny that's where my head's
coming from there's my head space and I
still enjoy this one about as much as I
enjoy order of the Phoenix so I will say
Harry Potter and the half-blood Prince
is a good time no alcohol required
alright guys so that's it we are now
caught up on the Harry Potter reviews I
could probably review Deathly Hallows
Part 1 and 2 since I reviewed them a few
years ago and I ultimately believe if
you have a movie review channel you
could review movies in the block of 5
years and just do those same movies
every 5 years same movie and they would
be different every time because you grow
your mind changes your experiences
change you and I'm sure if I reviewed
those movies now I would see them
through different eyes someone should do
that make a review channel where you
just do that every five years same
movies so we'll see what happens I don't
want to make a promise as it stands it's
been a really fun ride I've enjoyed the
Harry Potter marathon I forgot how much
I enjoyed those movies per my monologue
I just said before some of the ones I
remember not liking as much I liked a
lot more and vice-versa so I always find
that interesting learning a little bit
about yourself alright guys so Harry
Potter and the half-blood Prince have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]